Ends the heartache and the thousand naturals thoughts that flesh their sleep
To the consummations about these we wish to die
To sleep, to sleep, perchance to dream, aye, there's the rub
For in that sleep of death what dreams may come
When we have shuffled off this mortal toil must give us pause
There's the respect that makes calamity of so long life
For who would bear the wits and scorns of time
The oppressor's rawness, the proud man's contumely
The pangs of despised love, the laws of delay
The insolence of office and the spurns
That gish and merit of the unworthy takes
When he himself might in quietus make with a bare body
Who would marvel there to grunt and sweat under a weary life
But that the dredge of something after death
That undiscovered country from before no traveller returns
Puzzles the will and makes us rather bear those ills we have
Than fly to others that we know not of
Thus conscience doth make cowards of us all
And thus the native true of resolution is sick in o'er
With the pale cast of thought
And enterprises of great pith and moment
With disregard their currents turn awry
And cease the name of action
Thank you very much!